だからあの 心が街に建てるっていうことはね
そういうことで で 敵を全部排除しなくちゃいけないんです
で あの大体敵が外から来るんだというふうな仮定で考えちゃうと
この体にはこの窓口がね
1つありまして その窓口から情報が触れちゃうんですね
で そこで心がすごいやられてしまうんです
心が街であるならば 目という窓口から情報が入ると
心がすっくん もう混乱してやられてしまう
耳から音が入ると また心がやられてしまうという
だいたいは目と耳から入る情報だけで
もうかなりやられちゃいます
それはこの分析的に見ると
すごくもうくだらないってことはわかるんですよ
我々は決して素晴らしい美しい豪華なものを見てるわけじゃないんですよ
ただ この木を見ても あのもう高級デパートでディスプレーを見ても
ただ同じことなんですよ
問題は心にあって だからもうただそこを窓から見て木見える
今雨が降ってるんだから
そんなに立派に見えない
気持ち悪いとか思ったりして
そこでもう新宿に行ったら高級デパートがあって
そちらでも行ったりところで
ものすごい豪華な商品なので
なんてすごいでしょうかと思ったりするでしょうね
そこは我々心に問題があるんです
科学的に見れば 目があって目にただいろんなものを触れるだけ
耳があって耳にいろんな音が触れるだけのことで
我々心の中で大混乱を起こしちゃうんですね
ちょっと情報が入っただけで
だからそこで城壁を守らなくちゃいけない
そんなに大敵ってわけじゃないんですよ
ただ もう光として何か目に触れるだけ
それだけでそんなには混乱するのかと
耳でただ音が触れるだけで
それだけでこんなにも人格も変わって
犯罪も犯して もうどこまでやるのかと
たったそれだけのことで
で 舌にちょっと味が触れるだけで
鼻にちょっと香りが入るだけ
それもそんなにたくさんないでしょうに
で 体にも何か触れるだけ
大体鼻と舌と体っていうのはそれほどたくさん情報が我々は受け取らないんですけど
耳と目ですね ただ この 2つでどれほど人間っていうのはもうもうもう精神的にイカれしまって
もう人生そのものがダメになっちゃう場合もありますよ
ただそれだけのことで
目に入った情報で耳に入った情報で
情報というと またやりごわしい情報じゃなくて
ただ単に何か触れただけなんです
これが頭の中でもうむちゃくちゃなせて
精神的に病気になって
それでもう薬漬けになっちゃって
人生がそれで終わりということにまでなるんです
その時点でもう香りと味なんかはね
そこまで人を混乱させるということはないというかね
だから窓口が 1つありますね
その窓口からもう入る情報について我々は厳しいガードしなくちゃいけない
そのガードって何なのかというと
知恵なんですね だから知恵っていうのはもうなかなかこれまたわかりにくいところで
知恵っていうのは科学的に冷静に見るだけなんです
例えば人は死ぬものではありませんというのは
全ての人々はもう頑固と信じている話でしょう
ヴィパッサナー瞑想やってください
長生きできます 言った途端
いくらでも私にはこのうるさいやつらがいくらでも来るんです
2日で3日で4日であなたの病気治してみせましょうと言ったら
もういくらでも人は来るんですよ
だからそれは何なのかというと
人々はそう思っているんです
体は病気にならないもので
もう奇跡 奇跡は常にあるもので
いつでもそれで永遠な命はもういただくんだそうと
天に神様がいて 全知全能でお願いしたらすぐやってくれるんだと
神に勝るものはいるわけないでしょうとかね
それが世間の考え方なんですよ
それが智慧ではないと仏教は言うんですね
で それでブッダはなんで仏教といいながら他宗教を馬鹿にする？馬鹿にしているんじゃなくて
客観的に見てくださいと
例えば全知全能の神様が何でもできるんだったら
なんでお願いすることは一つ
たった一つぐらいやってくれたら罰が当たらんでしょ
あいつには たった一人の人間は 300年ぐらい寿命が延びるようにしてくれれば
信じてあげますけど で
かえって真剣真面目に神を信じちゃうと
不幸しかないというかね
廃寺になるからとかね
みんな早死にするんですよ
神信じてるんだから 互いに殺し合いやって
だからただ単に目を覚ませてみるだけ
例えばまあ そういう神様か仏様か誰かさんが入ってきて
もう自分の病気を綺麗さっぱり治してくれて
もう 200年  300年長生きしてくれるんだそうとか
信仰があるでしょうね
それで実際人間はそうなった人が一人か
たった一人でもいるのかと
ないでしょうね ただそれだけが智慧っていうのは
もうちょっと風邪引いただけでおどろいちゃってびっくりして
何がそれって見るだけの話なんです
どう考えたっても体も細胞だから
もう似てるもの触れちゃうと入り込むんですよ
あ そうか そうかで そういう
それで終わる話なんです
で ここら辺は外を見ると
今日は全然もう美しく見えないとか
暗いだけの話なんです
今日はすごく暗い だから今までは心だけ暗かったんですけど
今日はもう特別に環境も暗くなっているんです
で 二重暗さで気分が悪いと
それに何の神秘も何のこともない
[背景音楽]だから智慧っていうのはなかなか分かりにくいんですけど
もうただ心配になるだけなんです
何か見てびっくりするんじゃなくて
見えただけよと そんなの
だからこれで私はこちらで言うのは妄想の世界というね
心の中でももういくらでも妄想するという
ちょっと見えただけのことで
それからでもういくらでも妄想する
それでやられちゃいますね
だから自分でやられているだけなんですね
だから妄想っていうのはデータと関係なく結論を作ることでしょう
だからそれは常識で見ればおかしいんですね
例えば私は妄想できる人だったら
この本を持って この本は五千年古いんだよと堂々と言う
そうするとみんな笑っちゃうでしょうね
でも安心してください
皆様もそういうことを毎日毎日やっているんです
何の証拠もないことが堂々と言うことですよ
妄想っていうのは だからこの本は五千年古いんだよと言ったらもう笑っちゃうでしょうね
あんまりにもバカバカらしくて
それで私の反論は証拠は要りませんと
結論だけ十分ですとという反論で成り立っています
で この本は五千年古いと言ったら笑う人々は四六時中ずっと 1分たりとも止まることなく妄想はしている
妄想していて その結論で生きている
それには笑わないね だから自分に笑った方がいいんですよ
ものすごいおかしいんです
だから 目でちょっと何か見える
見えただけで 頭で考えて考えて考えて
それで証拠いらんだから何でも考えられます
だから妄想にはキリがないんですね
もうものすごい で ストップできないんですよ
だって原因がないということで妄想するんだから
どうやってストップできるんですかね
証拠はなくても大丈夫やという人にとっては何でも言えるでしょうに
その人どうやって止まるんですかね
証拠は必要ではありませんという前提で喋れば何でも喋る
この柱 これが金でできているんだ
これは これは石でできているんだと
証明はいらん 私はこれ石だと言ったんだから石ですと
この柱は金と言ったんだから金ですと
そんな考え方で我々は生きているんです
これちょっとやめてくださいというのが仏教の話なんです
ちょっと証拠に基づきなさいよと
この方が楽やと その方が楽でしょうに
例えばこの柱に触れてインスピレーションを働かせて何言おうかなと思ったら苦しいんじゃないんですかね
あの詩を書く人々と同じくすっごい苦しむんですよ
くだらんことを言うために
いわゆるよくイマジネーション
インスピレーションとか何とか言ってるでしょ？かっこいい言葉は
だからこの 楽なのはもう見た
見たままで止まった方が楽なんです
聞いたままで止まった方が楽なんです
だからあえて妄想するということをして
苦しいことっていうのはもう切りがない
とめなく苦しい だから妄想っていうのはそう簡単にストップはしないんですよ
例えば足を組んでいて痛くなったら足崩しちゃえば治るでしょ
これが死活問題にはなりません
困る必要もないんで 足を組んで痛くなったら足を伸ばした
あるいは足を崩したと
だから原因があって結果が知ってるんだったら
もうそこをやめればそれだけのことで
しかし 妄想をやめてくださいと言っちゃうとできますかと
例えば人を見る で 嫌な人だ
もう気持ち悪い人間だ
不細かな人やとか 自分が勝手に思うだけで
別になんのことなくちょっとした光が目に触れただけでしょうに
そこで なんで不細かな人やと思ったんでしょうか？という理由がないんですよ
何の理由もなくそう思っちゃう
だからこれがもう治らないんですね
だからそこはヴィパッサナー瞑想のチャレンジなんです
その証拠をなす いらんという証拠いらないんですが
私は何でも結論出してやるぞと
例えば人が死んじゃったら天国に行かれたと言うでしょ
そういう葬式に行って
何々さんが亡くなりましたと
天国に何て召されたでしたっけ
召されたと 堂々とノコノコとみんな嘘言ってるんだと
私は知ってる限りはこの友人は死んだだけですと
生きている時は随分仲良くしていましたと
こういうこういういいこともしましたと
だから死んで悲しいと
いう風な あの 何式言うんですか
あれは 弔辞したらとんでもないことになるでしょう
ではなくて かっこいい弔辞っていうのは
弔辞っていうのはもう天国にいる誰かに喋ってるんです
それが何でみんなの前でやるんですかね
あの祭壇なんか作って
それ見て あんなことを堂々とやってるでしょうに
だからいかに人間 だからこれが五年古いということは
なんで笑い者になるんですかね
人間やってることは何でもそういう笑い者なんです
事実言っちゃうと もうもう大変なことになります
私は自分の国で葬式で言うことは
そのまま日本訳して日本人に言っちゃうと
どうなるかと ありのままの事実を言うんです
死んだ人を褒め称えて天国にいる何々さんとかいったことも言わない
向こうは仏教の世界だから
そういう風に説法すると
みんな随分身を乗り出して聞いてくれるんです
遺体はもう無関心もう
時々若坊主たちに私は言うんです
あいつらは先生の言うことを聞いてくれないんですけどね
お前らできればそういう風に説法してみなさいと
どんな大長老が来たっても
お葬式なんかでは誰も話聞いてくれないでしょうと
じゃあ私が言ったらどうですかと
みんな身を乗り出して聞いてるんではないかと
やっぱりありのままのことを聞くと結構気分がいいんです
それはやっぱり仏教の世界で
その環境に限ることなんです
日本でありのままの聞く聞くと
もう皆様に能力ないだけで
私のVISAは 24時間でもう取り消すと思います
できればできないだけ
悪いことに皆様の協力何一つなくてもVISA取れるんです
私 だから やっぱりそのその社会によってそれぞれ
考えが違いますけど 仏教の社会ではやっぱりありのままに言った方がみんな
良いことをすれば天国に行くんだぞというよりは
逆を言うとみんな聞いてくれるんです
あんた方はね たまたま何かいいことしたんだからといって調子に乗るんじゃないんだよと 24時間悪いことしてるんだから
計算してみれば罪の方が重いんだよと覚悟しろと言った方がみんなじっと聞いているんです
本当のこと言うんだから
ちょっとしたいいことすると
これを褒めて褒めて褒めまくっちゃうと
本当にもうよくお坊さんたちやってますよ
ちょっと法事なんかに行ったら褒めまくるんですね
褒めまくるんだけど 信者さんが全然反応がないんです
時々もう逆に言うんですね
もっともらいたいんだから
それで全部チャラになっちゃう
あの説法は ある家で説法に行って
悪ガキ 2人  3人ぐらいいたんですね
そいつらはさっさと前に座って
座っただけではなくて
説法だけは絶対聞かんと
態度なんです で 一人一人もうもうもうもうるっぴり
もうもう顔ももうもう最初はもう見るんですけど
見てもう横顔見て まあ座った時点で
まあそいつは聞くつもりはないというのをよくわかるんです
私もまあ無関心で まあじゃあもういいやということで
それでお母さんのもう座ってるんだから
お母さんの膝のところにも
もう膝に頭つけて膝枕で寝ているんです
寝ている時でももう壁を見て寝ているんです
ここら辺見ると私が見えますからね
で それで私はもう子供はもうもう関係ないということで
もうかなり難しいところ
いろんなことを言ってるんです
説法で でもこいつはもう寝ているんですけど
いろいろ喋るんです 私言うことに何か言うんですよ
で これまたぴったし反論する
反論じゃないんです 何て言いますか
相筋というかね これぴったしなんです
結局 あんな小さな子供のくせに話聞くつもりはないけど
結局は聞いているんです
聞いてるだけな大人よりわかってるね
何言ってるのかと で 説法あって顔も見ないで帰りましたけども
帰ったんですけど もうそういう
そんな態度なんですね
随分失礼な態度出るんです
で なぜかというと よく考えちゃうと
もうまあ決まってるパターンで言うんだから
子供に言うと面白くないんですね
決まってるパターン破って
ありのままに言うと子供にでも理解できるという
自分に関係ないことを言ってる間は無関心でいて
なんか自分に関係すると
またもう子供なんとか何とかごちゃごちゃごちゃごちゃ言ったりする
そこで喋ってる間 全然邪魔にもなりません
見事にこの話の流れに嵌めるんです
この子供の反論というか
この反応 そういうことで
この事実は反対だと 真理に反対っていうのは世間の生き方なんです
嘘は 3世で真理に反対だっていうね
で だからお釈迦様もこれはこの流れに逆らう道であると
流れっていうのは世間の考え方なんですね
それが残念なことに全てまとめて嘘なんです
全て妄想から作り出した世界なんです
美も何でもかんでも けど苦しいんですよ
まあ特に 特にエンターテインメントの世界ね
美の世界というかね 娯楽の世界っていうのは楽しみためのあるものでしょ
楽しいんですかね？一かけらも楽しみないんです
この娯楽の世界で 地獄の苦しみなんですよ
ものすごく信じられないほど苦行しますよ
ちょっとしたこの二 三分の歌を歌うために
並った人の苦しむことじゃ苦しいことじゃないんです
それであれほど苦しんで苦しんで訓練して
またもうそんなに金にもならないし
これ聞いてすごく良かったと思いますかね
私はなんかえらい心配ビクビクしているんです
あーやっと終わってよかったよかった
よかったっていうのは
その本人の気分や気分
気分に乗ってるんです
無事で終わってよかったと
でなきゃその人どういうことになるかわからないと
親の心で聞いているんです
この舞台なんかはね もう重労働ですよ
どこに楽しみがあるのかと
でも やってる側も見る側も最高やと思ってるんです
死ぬまで舞台でやるぞと
あのばあちゃんと連中がいいと思ってるんです
だから娯楽世界は口だけ娯楽
中身はもうもう何ですかね
極端な苦なんです で 一つの歌をレコーディングするために
これもう三ヶ月ぐらい苦労してるでしょうに
大変です だから嘘に決まってますよ
娯楽って言っても娯楽じゃないんです
あれは これでちょっともう三十分ぐらい歩いてみたらいかがでしょうかというと
これにも逆らうこと 三十分時間
そんな時間がないんだよ
随分忙しいですね いかに嘘を言っているのかと
だから証拠いらんだからね
忙しい 証拠いらんでしょ
何やって忙しいんですかねと聞きたいんですけど
そう聞いちゃうと失礼です
日本の 何て言いますか
習慣わかってない この人は
[背景音楽]忙しいの
あんた仕事は何？仕事やってないんだという
仕事もない割に瞑想する暇がないと
と言うんだから だから我々は嘘の塊で生きているんだということはブッダの言葉なんです
で それに反対するのは気持ちわかりますよ
人間っていうのは真面目に嘘を言っているわけじゃないんだから
自分が言っていることは正しいと思っているでしょうに
だからそこら辺で正しいことを言っているのに
忙しいんだから忙しいんだと言っているんだよと
私もよく言うんだよ 忙しいんだから来るなよと
電話かけるなよと私に
誰も忙しい何やってるのかと聞かないんです
知ってるんだからね 私は忙しいというと
何やってるのかと 何にもやってないんです
で 何にもやってないということは
私はすごく忙しい 誰も邪魔してほしくない
もう歯も磨けませんよ
こいつ何も活動ない休みの日がある場合はね
忙しい その日はもうご飯も食べないんです
なぜか忙しいんです だからもう誰かが電話がものすごく嫌なんですね
電話に出る暇がないんです
しかし 誰も聞かない 忙しい
何やっていたんですか？と聞いちゃうと
言うんです 何にもやらないことで忙しいんだと
それわからないでしょ
何にもやらないことで忙しいってことはわからないと思います
真面目に忙しいんですよ
冗談じゃないんです 自分が自分の世界に踊るんです
自分の世界というのは結構大胆で恐ろしいんです
普通考えることを考えません
ものすごい微妙な ビッサイなもう独り勝手に心は扱っているんだ
だからもう忙しい もう並大抵の世界線じゃないんです
だから歯を磨いたりお風呂に入ったりと
そんな暇がないんです
ご飯食べる暇がないんです
具体的には何やったんで
何にもやってない まあとにかくまあそれぞれ忙しい人はいろいろあるかもしれませんですけど
まあ皆様忙しいっていうのは全く意味が違うと思います
まあ心を動かさないでいるっていうことはね
できないんだからね 心を動かさないでいるっていうことで
結構忙しいんですよ でも気分的にはもう忙しいんだからね
気分悪くないんです 誰でもね
本当に忙しくて いろいろやることいっぱいやるとね
気分悪くないでしょ まあ世間はやっぱりなんかこの自分たちが真面目に本当のことを言って思って生活してるんだというふうにこの思っている
だからブッダの話っていうのはすごいもう失礼に感じたりもする
もう嘘つきだというと
これ失礼でしょう で なぜ失礼なのかというと
この我々の妄想で組み立てた生き方自体が嘘っていうことに気づいてないんです
娯楽は明らかに楽しいものだと決まりつけているんだから
本気でそう思っているんです
あの美空ひばり 美空ひばりさんという方がもう確かに能力ありますよ
それは文句はないんです
で それに食べているんです
能力なきゃもうね お金入りませんだから
まあそれぐらいだったらその分正直でいいのに
で 嘘の世界で生きていて
それで最後にも何か舞台やりたいと
もう病気でもう大変で立っていられないんですよ
立つとものすごい苦痛だそうです
倒れるぐらいまで それで最後の舞台やりましたからね
ものすごいド派手に みんな感動する
あれって残酷じゃないんですかね
長いなんか舞台でなんか歩くなんか高くて
そこでちゃんと歩いて
ちょっと踊りながら歌っていくとかね
これ 3時間ぐらいやってるでしょ
車椅子でいなくちゃいけない人が
それで舞台に見せる顔だから
かすかにでもここら辺
もう強烈な痛みが出てくると
倒れるんですけど かすっても顔で見せないでニコニコニコニコ穏やかな顔を見せたりしてね
だからそれが それが評価するならばね
なんという勇気ですか
なんという欲ですかと
傲慢とか自我っていうのは大したもんやと評価すれば大したもんですよ
それはほかの人いないんです
私もその方は評価しますよ
でも評価する見方が違うんです
だからこの作った世界で
おとぎ話の世界で 一時的な観念的な楽しみにどれほど執着していたかというと
それだけあればどんな苦労も惜しまないという
あれほど苦労するのに
なんのことない  30分で
3時間で全部終わり ビデオを撮っているんだから残っているだけのことで
皆様一人もそこを見ていないと思いますけど
私は見ているわけじゃないんですけど
ニュースで知っているだけで
参加した人々にしたっても
その時点で終わりでしょう
しかし ちょっと 30分ゆっくり歩けと言えば
どれほど嫌だと言うんでしょうかというと
だから どれほど我々はこのインチキの世界に粘りすぎているのかということ
だから そこでミシェル・オバマさんという方にしても
もう娯楽の世界だと言っても
これはもう空想のものの世界で本人が生きているんですね
だからどちらが事実ですかね
車椅子で歌えばいいでしょうに
歌えるところだけは能力は衰えなかったんですからね
だったら車椅子で歌えばいいでしょう
あんな意匠気なことやって
やっぱり世間の妄想の世界
そういう世界で この事実ではないのに事実だと言っちゃうんですね
それで私たちの心は街に例えてみるんだから
このこの 5つの窓口からほんのわずかな何か触れるだけのことで
どうったことない つまらないんですよ
目に形だけ映るんだよと言っちゃうとすごいつまらないでしょうね
その形だけ映るなのに
それで我々は妄想してインチキ世界どれほど作っているのかというと
このインチキ世界が事実だと思っているところはもうさらに問題であって
だからヴィパッサナーってやり方で知恵使っちゃえば全部潰れてしまいますよと
それで本格的な錯覚世界現れますよと
そこでアニメへの執着する
執着する何もないんです
というところで最後の言葉で済ませているんです
自分に打ち勝つと 打ち勝ちなさいと
自分に打ち勝つ方法で知恵というものを使ってます
知恵は武器なんですね
知恵っていうのはただありのままに見るだけのことで
余計な妄想しないで 妄想ってのはすっごいタチが悪いんですよ
だから証拠なくてもいいんじゃないかと言っちゃうと
もう成り立たんですよ
世界は だから成り立たないんです
この世界は 妄想っていうのは何の証拠もない
の世界でしょうしね まあこの偈の説明といえば
まあこんなところかなと思いますね
まあ四十一番目はないんだから
テキペイントはね 四十で終わるまで行ったんです
ジータンっていうのは解脱のことですか？ 何？ このジータン
ジータンという言葉ないんですけど
一番最後の最初に 勝利っていう
自ターンですね  自ターン
解脱するでしょうね そういうことで
まあ一応あの体は水瓶のようにちょっと叩いただけで壊れるものであると
で 心は町のようにとんでもない大変なもの
これがもう敵を全部叩き直せないと
だから町がもう最高なものと最低なものは全部揃っているところだからね
最低なものは排除すればね
まあいいということで
それでまあ一応眼耳鼻舌身から入る情報で我々は混乱しているんだから
そこら辺で管理するということの説明はできたんです
で また一般的に我々が言うこの妄想というね
内の戦いというね それを内で妄想という世界を作って
それが事実だと勘違いして
この我々はすぐ世間を作っているんです
だから妄想は単なる妄想だと覚えておれば
まあそれだけで結構楽にはなります
で 妄想の流れは止まってもらえばそれこそ勝利である
それが知恵がないと止まるわけじゃないんです
事実を見る限りね 発見しない限りは
それ事実っていうのはとてもシンプルで
とても発見しやすいんです
だから 正しく言っている通りに修行してみれば
まあ真理に目覚めるということは当然のことなんです
難しいことじゃないんです
我々はただその勇気がないだけ
例えば自分がすぐ死んで腐りかけるものだとね
水瓶のように まあ手で叩いたっても壊れる体やと
死んじゃいますと それぐらいのこと
これおっかない 危ないんだと
まあなんか風船にずっと水をもう入れたような感じだと思っちゃえばいいんじゃないですかね
風船は空気を入れてもそれなりにいくらかは楽しい
水入れちゃうとものすごいもろいんです
ものすごいもろいんです
で 空気 例えばある程度で大きく空気入れられるでしょうね
そちらの三分の二ぐらい水を入れてみれたら
大きさで もう持てないんです
持っただけでも割れちゃうんです
そんなもんですよ この体は
ちょっとしたことでも
何のことね 頭にビニール袋かぶっちゃえば
窒息して死ぬですよ そんなもんですよ
だからそこを見てちょっと怖くならないとね
こんなものを張って堂々できるんじゃなくて
人殺してでも生きてみるぞってことじゃなくて
これはもう危ないと ジリジリと死を感じてすごく怖くなるんですよ
そこが勇気なんです それで心清らかにすることはできるんです
その人は足が痛いとかね
ちょっと熱くなったとかね
そんなことなんかことは言わんと思います
では そこで話を終了させていただきます
今日はあまり役に立たなかった
台風のせいでちょっと情報が出てこないんです
電波は切れてるんです
どうもありがとうございます